[Music]
welcome back to awesome record where we
talk about
whatever we want today we got frankie
with us
aka cholo fitz
is this the first time you make an
appearance without your creeper outfit
nah nah i do that okay i was like yo are
we exposing the the there's more to me
bro
i got creeper in my bag right here no
way oh that's
how did you come up with that character
like how did it all start i was
mostly based off my father and then it
was like an old school troll and then
and then my cousins like kind of all a
thing of that but like all that you know
embracing all of that
but my dad's just old school trollo he's
had a low rider always chuck taylor's
dickies and
one of the most positive people you know
what i mean so yeah when he sees you
doing comedy he's like
[ __ ] disgrace he's with it man he's
supportive he's like
[ __ ] i wanted a gangster son but damn i
got a clown
my dad's not a gangster but he is kind
of like old school he's kind of like
just like that serious asian man
super snowy so when i told him i wanted
to do a career in
trying to make other people laugh you
pretty much thought i was like the
biggest [ __ ] in the world
yeah or he's like get a real job
yeah my my mama pops they were like i
was always like that i was always that
class clown
[ __ ] like that you know what i mean
always kind of getting in trouble and
i'll perform for them
like my dad was would work construction
i found an old sprinkler head in his in
his uh
car because we he we didn't have like
money for like a real like setup but i
would have like uh
i would get like a the sprinkler head
and pretend it was a mic and i'll
perform for like my
and they'd be like all right here he
goes again turn off the tv see what he's
got
all right let's see what 10 minutes bro
[Music]
or if it's not working out turn on the
water yeah yeah
so when did you guys get the idea to
start uh doing entertainment and stuff
like that
i i'm pretty much i was always
fascinated by it when i was a kid
because my mom and pops always had they
always had music playing or they always
had comedy on tv
and uh even when i was you know even
times they were struggling i saw how it
would get them through and my mom
my mom was always a jokester my dad's
more calm he's like chill
yeah my mom's like the one that's like
oh [ __ ] it's gonna be all good
don't trip like you know i'm like we
would get like the power turned off and
she would have like a boom boxer like
she put batteries in
and she put put on jams or like comedy
and just light candles and just like
start like
you just make fun like make it a good
time that's tight so that [ __ ] was like
as i got older
because you know when you're little you
don't really know like you know you're
like you're like oh this is just oh cool
mom's making it fun like okay i hope the
power goes out again
when the power goes out it was fun it
was so fun you get to listen to the
ballpark
as you got older you're like oh [ __ ]
they were going through some [ __ ] then i
was more like inspired like or it was
just like
to see how powerful like humor and music
and all that [ __ ] could be
and then so they would let me watch
stand up when i was little eddie murphy
paul rodriguez
george carlin all them dudes they just
cover your you cover yours in the bad
parts of me huh you're like
okay
[Laughter]
and like this doesn't really do nothing
anyway like let's be real like earmuffs
don't really work
this is the trick kids go like this cup
your hands you can still hear
everything yeah yeah that's smart so
yeah off camera you're telling me did
stand up for what 16 years or something
yeah oh me out i was like because i'm 40
now so
yeah i think i was about 23 22 23
even even when i was in high school i
played some sports but
but i would do like some improv [ __ ] and
i was always
into it but in some in some way but then
uh yeah when i was like 23 or 24 i went
to my first open mic did someone invite
you or you're like i'm just gonna try
this well i have been talking about it
with some homies and there was a homie
of mine
uh danny contreras a good dude he does
like sound now for like espn and [ __ ]
but uh
i dare you he was he was in there like
he's like april you've been talking
about doing stand up so he found this
he found this cafe i know i had like an
open mic night and he was like
hey and i was like all right [ __ ] you
know and also i'm nervous as [ __ ] we're
in my little
three minute set uh it was mostly
diarrhea jokes
those are killed all you have to do is
say diarrhea in this room dude you're
good
you're winning already diarrhea jokes
don't work your [ __ ] really sucks
i wouldn't be surprised if we had over
100 episodes on just [ __ ] alone
that's conservative that's very
conservative yeah even [ __ ] on me we're
all dead with diarrhea
did you grow up here in l.a yeah well i
was born i was born here in l.a and then
we lived in the valley
uh san fernando valley uh and then we
moved to oxnard
and camarillo and then i lived in the
bay san francisco for like 15 years
i've been back here in l.a for going on
nine years now yeah be honest are you a
bidet user
homie i was like what like well he was
just saying he was impressed that we
have bidet
be honest though yeah yeah let's get
real here let's get real no no i [ __ ]
with the bass
i like the base too i [ __ ] with bidet is
hard
like at first it was weird to me but i
had a homie
uh who i danced baleful i danced for
level which is mexican folk dancing
you know back in the day for like i did
that [ __ ] for like eight years nine
years and uh
and i had a homie that i was in the
dance and hit they had a bidet
just randomly yeah and they live in and
they didn't live in a big pad it was a
they lived in the same neighborhood it
was like a you know just a two-bedroom
single-story house next to like a farm
and [ __ ]
yeah they were like and then but they
were about a bidet
you know and they had one in their home
and i was like what the [ __ ] is that
like that's a bold move too right
especially early on like that
[Laughter]
you know and then you're like [ __ ] is
this like does this make me weird
you have a [ __ ] breakdown what do i
like
a man has to look himself in the mirror
and decide if he's okay with this
eventually at some point in the shower
put your hands up for a second
like what have i done
it's not that i like it it's practical
it's practical it's it's it's cleaner
than if i
weren't using it that's why you didn't
like you have a [ __ ]
less paper less paper i get it let's
paper it's a game changer though
it'll change your life bro yeah once you
get past it because this was before
there was an internet where i could look
it up and see it was like a normal thing
oh that's the first time i saw it so i
used it and then i go home to my mom and
dad and i feel weird
i have a confession like hey you got me
home like yeah everything's fine
i don't like it
[Laughter]
i gotta say it's a slippery slope
because my wife eats my [ __ ] and i
didn't like that before wait you're
watching
this goes in on my [ __ ] now i know
dude it's amazing it's i love it
i love it totally wait what do you mean
it goes into your [ __ ] now like after
she found out he's a bidet she was down
i started using the bidet right clean
now you know slippery slope though yeah
it is
now i need my [ __ ] eating everything
so what's next dude
i can't even get hard i can't even get
harder come on hold on i can't get hard
unless you're good
it's like anally stimulated yeah that's
the fact hey that's tight
i
i put both hands up in the shower
[Laughter]
she motorboats his [ __ ] wait so she
does it in the shower
she doesn't do it
[Laughter]
i am i thought you were joining my party
man
i'm sorry i was so happy hey joe sells
it though when joe talks about getting
his ass
he sells it yo it's the it's the new age
blow job yeah
but on the [ __ ] if you're not doing
it you're [ __ ] lame bro he's awesome
he's changing a lot of lives this way
he's got a lot of messages from people
who are like hey dude i was thinking
about i was in a dark place
i was thinking about doing maybe
something self-harm but then i heard
about eating getting my [ __ ] today
and it changed everything and you
rescued me you're telling me
getting your butthole eaten feels better
than the actual [ __ ]
now yeah oh i've had a lot of [ __ ]
you finished to to not getting your ass
off bro
that's [ __ ] fatigue he got it too
much he got his dick sucked too much
congratulations
[Laughter]
must be nice huh having a double action
tugging rim that's the [ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah yeah
i'm a fan and then you [ __ ] bust that
way oh my god [ __ ] bellagio water
show right there can't go back
that [ __ ] orchestra music comes on
and [ __ ]
say goodbye the first time i got my eso
leg i was
i was like it was it was definitely whoa
like what are you doing
yeah but then once you got it oh [ __ ]
okay after the bidet experience
short grip and stuff like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
i always picture the chick afterwards
though because she has to go to the
bathroom and then she looks herself in
the mirror and she's got like ass
and [ __ ] juices on her mouth like she's
ass juices only like
think about it i thought you use a bidet
you predate it but at least like some
ass spit or whatever
and i always think about the chick like
just turning on the faucet and looking
at herself knowing what she just did
yeah that's like you can't have bears in
the bathroom like that yeah that's true
that's what it is
too many realizations that's smart
that's smart yeah just [ __ ]
look take a nap and forget about it it's
a new day i'm more of a poet i'm sorry
today's video is brought to you by hello
tushy
do you have a butthole if you do then
this
ad is for you so i love bidets because
when you poop
your butt sticky and the cleanest i have
ever felt
is with using a bidet but the problem is
most bidets are very very
expensive that's why i didn't have one
for a long time yeah and the brand new
hello tushie 3.0 it's actually really
affordable so everyone can have one yep
so it's super
easy to install and the cool thing is
they have this option where not only
does it spray your butt one way but if
you do it the other way
it cleans itself that's awesome and one
other thing that's super cool
is what's unique about this is it
attaches to your existing toilet so you
don't need
electricity you don't have to run
plumbing it just attaches right to it
and it works
and it's super eco-friendly because it
cuts toilet paper use
by 80 percent and the sanitation
is simple too because even the knobs are
naturally
antimicrobial and it's super simple you
just poop spray
dry and then go peace out bye bye
and what's super cool is that every
tushy bidet attachment
comes with a 60-day money-back guarantee
so you could try it use it see if your
butthole likes it if not
you could send it back and a 12-month
warranty
yup and i have the 2.0 and i've had it
now for about like
two years and i never had to get it
fixed
never had to return it and it's been
pretty cool so go to hellotushy.com
off director to get 10 off plus free
shipping
hellotushy.com off the record
for 10 off plus free shipping and it's
worth it because you have the cleanest
butthole ever and you're gonna love it
so much and you're gonna look at your
underwear and go wow
i don't have the scars anymore i don't
have the battle marks anymore it's just
nice and clean
no more streaks of shame baby no no no
no no no more wolverines
claw marks or any of that kind of stuff
you ever been to japan collection
because they got bidets and public
restrooms out there oh yeah
they got the temperature the the the
seats with the temperature
in public bathrooms actually tripped me
out and the the vending machines on me
with the [ __ ] soil chonies in there
[ __ ] soil underwear available for
purchase little kids walking by the [ __ ]
yeah it's a real thing and it'll be like
in a public space and you just
put the money into what else do they
have just in case a pervert needs a face
yeah what else is in the vending
machines is it just like underwear or is
it like other stuff like that no no
there's all kinds of [ __ ] cigarettes
soiled underwear like little
you know the usual [ __ ] chocolate milk
there's a lot of vending machines that
have like full-on food like gold bricks
like wagyu
[ __ ] a5 meat like wow it's just it's
just the novelty
but it's not not the norm the norm is
just like a bunch of drinks and [ __ ]
yeah damn dude but there's like places
like a mall where you just go in and the
whole thing's just vending machines yeah
i've seen that yeah and they got all
kinds of [ __ ] in there
but i love how they have the little
chill stations too but they keep them
transparent like a window so fools don't
[ __ ] start jerking off in there
oh yeah that probably isn't right a spot
for like half an hour and you just chill
in there read the newspaper and
lay down take it do you have those yeah
what do they call it little pods uh yeah
pot like little pods
jerk pods jerk they got jerk pods too
yeah yeah no when we were there there
was um i wanted to know what it was i
didn't go in
i'm surprised i know i wasn't alone
i'll go next time you know and i wasn't
single so it was like an
awkward thing but then i looked it up
online
and what what what they are is like
there's these
jackoff stalls and then they do peep
shows oh oh so
like in different positions like they're
taken like that where the girl comes out
and there's like
metal things that come up i just
visualized the same thing yeah i don't
know
is it like hostile that movie i don't
take what's like that's like
a two-way mirror or one-way mirror yeah
where the girl can't see any of the
dudes but all the dudes around can see
the girl she's just dancing or whatever
and all the guys they get to just jack
off and they're all
it's like that imagine if she could see
everybody oh that'd be weird huh well
she probably
just sees all these dudes like
they have some spots yeah yeah like what
do you call them the not the arcades but
miniature golf the peeps show
[ __ ] but yeah i've been to one one time
and you just it just smells funky in
there and you see the homie cleaning up
and you're like
like just helicopter i'm hoping that he
gets getting paid sometimes how would
you describe the smell i mean it smells
like
like like nuts it's like nut and bleach
did you go there on a uh to do like uh
like
like a performance or whatever no no no
we were just like i mean this was years
ago it was a long time ago and then it
was it yeah [ __ ] man what was it called
for research lucky lady or something
it's for research
and you go we went with some homegirls
also i was like all right cool and then
but it was the same thing you put some
money in and then
the thing comes up and there's a girl
dancing oh i meant to japan
oh oh yeah are you okay
japan i've never been to the peep show
talking about what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah we're into japan yeah
tokyo that's the reason why we got
bidets too
is because after we're like oh it's not
the same because everywhere you go
you just have a clean ass yeah so then
when you come back you're like we need
to get those and that's a trip that they
have
like where you could control the
temperature even what type of spray goes
into the ass like you want it kind of
spritzy or you want the streamline
yeah you want a [ __ ] enema or if you
how hard you want it to be
if you want a little lighter yeah i mean
it's all warm and [ __ ] i don't know how
they get public bathrooms in the park
so clean that's because they got the
bidet homie oh yeah that's true less
cleanup you know what i mean
and like it almost makes you want to be
clean it makes you respect the space a
little more like oh [ __ ]
but then you're all right i want to
leave i don't want to be the one to
leave a mess you know there's a robot
this is expensive don't [ __ ] it up and
then another thing is a trippy when we
went to
i've been to the middle east a handful
of times and performed at like military
bases and [ __ ] but
everywhere out there there's a hole in
the ground you know public bathrooms you
go in
you know it's porcelain and all that but
it's just in the ground yeah
and you gotta like scrounge down you
know and then oh they do squatters too
because they have shower heads too
you ever seen those like it's like it's
like a little hole and then a shower
head so just wash your hands yeah oh
that's like that's how they get down too
which is also kind of nice
if you want it there it's a nice option
to have yeah and i prefer the
the handheld low-key because you know
when the day starts going you kind of
gotta
it's never it's never it's never on
bullseye for me
i
you gotta be loud on your feet a little
bit you're like oh [ __ ] okay
dude some guys need the hole in the
ground though like like
men i'm talking about like like p when
it's p time
i would like it if some guys would just
[ __ ] lay on that hole
yeah yeah they wouldn't get all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere yeah some
bathrooms i see it i'm like how the [ __ ]
does this happen why is there [ __ ] like
on the back part of it like why is there
[ __ ] over here like that's why we need
guys to i'm down to like have guys wear
a patch and they have to [ __ ]
go face forward in the hole and plank
because some foes i think some people's
pee holes are [ __ ] up like where they
don't have a double stream
i mean that happens sometimes like if
you're you know got a limp ball in there
or something but
like a phillips head
[Laughter]
i remember i went into a bathroom one
time and i saw this
trail of [ __ ] you could tell that this
fool couldn't make it he pulled down his
pants
and shot at the back and it went
straight down into the toilet
and then you just saw like a spray going
like you could tell that this will win
all the way down and you just saw a line
like that and i just saw
but if he missed his pants he had to be
like yes
i was just because it does become a fun
little game to see how long
it takes you to [ __ ] go take a [ __ ]
you know how long you hold it
like i made it home i mean it's a fun
little game that i like to play
i [ __ ] on the walls at am pm before no
way on
how i was like 12 or 13 though and we
went we
go to vegas with my family we're back at
like this station wagon
me and my cousin sonic and then and and
i told my dad but we were like in the
middle of nowhere you know driving from
vegas yeah
and then uh you know i was like [ __ ] i
got a [ __ ] and i'm trying to hold it and
i'm sweating and [ __ ] and then
i finally pull up to this am pm and i i
i like couldn't even i barely got my
pants down and it should just boom
like projectile yeah and then i sat down
and i looked back and i couldn't believe
it the [ __ ] was on the wall
and i'm like [ __ ] and then and then i
looked down at my shorts i was wearing a
pair of like khaki shorts
and i looked down and it sprayed on the
back of my head
and i'm like what do you do what's next
i'm like
so i finish and i get up and i walk out
sideways because i don't want the the
register homie to see me yeah
so i'm kind of like walking south oh
thanks
i told my dad i said pops i [ __ ] this
will happen and he's like [ __ ]
so he gets a plastic bag yeah you know i
take my shorts off he puts it in
in the plastic bag and ties it up throws
it in the car yeah then we just kept it
moving homie but i was like that's the
first time that i like what about the
wall
you didn't do nothing for the walk they
got like a blood spatter
analyst in there and he's like looking
at all this [ __ ] like [ __ ] dexter the
red strings
okay how did he pull his pants off right
at this moment
[Laughter]
that cash register guy was like yo that
kid was cool as [ __ ] bro
the way he was walking out all slick i
do this cool
[ __ ] man no way he did that no [ __ ]
way i don't believe you imagine apple
goes into the bathroom
he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] kidding me
you gotta sign the little paper and
leave and [ __ ] like i cleaned it
what would stand up like during covet
it's fine it just wasn't there on me
did you do shows in the past year we did
like the driving shows where the cars
you know like uh we did a couple like
ones at parking garages on the roof or
they'll blow up the screen like in those
inflatable screens and then yeah and
then there's a stage oh too
but then it's it's like we were talking
about like they when the audience thinks
something funny they'll hunt their horn
flash their lights
oh they they they give them a radio
station to dial into and that's how they
hear
yeah so when they honk does that give
you like a little bit of feedback do you
are you building off
honestly it wasn't as weird as i thought
it was going to be you know i mean i was
like oh this is going to be [ __ ]
weird
because the zoom shows were weird like
yeah where i figured out quickly like i
wasn't
like stand up like to just do straight
up stand up wasn't working for me on
zoom right yeah so i just started doing
other
[ __ ] like telling a story or [ __ ] you
know just talking about what happened
that day or whatever like
just kind of or just like you know
making it more or it wasn't that where
there's like zero feedback right it's
like in the beginning but
little by little zoom shows start
getting better where you get some you
can see people laughing but you don't
hear it
kind of like that no no there was some
there's some shows that do it where
people have their mics on like in their
living rooms and all that so you could
hear them laughing yeah you could even
talk to them and
those are like my favorite ones but most
of them are not getting no feedback
so you're like [ __ ] man especially if
you're trying to work on some new jokes
like you don't even know like i'm like
or do you joke because you know we all
had zoom calls do you do the joke
you finish your joke and then they're
like oh and you're like all wasn't done
i'm like oh sorry hold on
and then they wait and then they laugh
[Laughter]
that awkward [ __ ] thing that we all
do
even zoom meetings are weird homie so
imagine like trying to stand up at the
zoo
because everybody's like interrupting
each other like oh [ __ ] oh sorry all
right
right there okay now you go hey and the
heckler guy's like hey you suck oh wait
hold on did you hear that
oh sorry i had my headphones on let's
read the last joke i didn't mean that
joke that was pretty good
you